so i think the first thing we are going
to talk about
uh is the chauvin verdict
and i don't want to delve too deeply
into the particulars
um frankly i think many people were
absolutely
glued to their screens looking at the
details of the trial as they unfolded
and obviously people were tied up in uh
in many cases in
rooting one way or the other for a
verdict but what i do want to talk about
is the implications of
what happened um that is to say
we have a conviction uh on three counts
that um followed very short jury
deliberation in which they apparently
asked no questions and
in a wider context that was frankly
bizarre and quite jarring in which
maxine waters and the president
both appeared to urge the jury toward
a particular conclusion and
what i want to highlight is that this
was exactly the fear that i expressed
on joe rogan last year
my concern was that we obviously have a
very dangerous
and volatile situation where
we've had violent riots in the case
of portland we've had them uh months on
end on a nightly basis ostensibly tied
to this verdict and or to this situation
and
what it reveals um and
the problem is that we
obviously had the danger of renewed
violence
were the verdict to have been not guilty
on the other hand we have a standard in
this country
of reasonable doubt we have the burden
on the state
to prove its case and the facts of this
case
were highly complex in effect
the state needed to prove that a
reasonable officer knowing what chauvin
knew
would not have acted as chauvin
did um they also needed to prove
that george floyd didn't die
from other conditions that just happened
to occur
during the uh the progress of this
complex arrest and in both cases there
are tremendous reasons for
doubt so in any case without
focusing too much on the details the
question
is this did this jury conclude what it
concluded because of what was presented
in court and because the arguments were
persuasive where they needed to be or
did it conclude that for other reasons
such as a belief that some larger sort
of justice required
this answer which frankly in the context
of a sitting president
urging a jury towards an apparent
verdict and a member of congress doing
the same
this is very very frightening and
for those who haven't thought deeply
about it the the issue in question is
this
the founders of the country
created an environment in which the
state had a tremendous burden that it
needed to overcome
in court for a reason because the danger
of the state
not meeting such a burden uh left the
state in an asymmetrically powerful
position
so in other words it's not that the
founders weren't aware that a
preponderance of the evidence meaning
the evidence said more this than that
was available because of course that's
what we have in civil trials but in
criminal trials they wanted to hobble
the state
and ensure that the state had to prove
something
beyond a reasonable doubt in order to
protect the rest of us from the state
now in this case
we have another factor which is
effectively mobs engaged in violence
demanding an outcome and we have the
state
appearing to be persuaded
by those mobs such that the executive
saw fit to intervene
in the decision-making process of jurors
so whether or not chauvin is actually
guilty he's obviously been convicted so
in a technical sense he is guilty
whether he was actually guilty and it
was proven
beyond a reasonable doubt in court in
this venue
is another question but the hazard of
allowing a situation in which public
violence persuades the state to put its
thumb on the scales of a trial a
criminal trial the danger of that is
impossibly great and what
is absolutely shocking to me
is that people do not seem to understand
that the the burden of the state to
prove guilt beyond a reasonable doubt to
a jury of one's peers
that is the thing that protects us this
isn't about show and this is about 350
million of us who are protected
from the state's aggression by
that counterintuitive innovation
and my concern is that we are
uninventing it
i'm sorry i i lost you at the end which
counter-intuitive so i was going to make
a point and i lost your logic at the
very end sorry about that
um my point is the idea that the state
should have to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt is
counterintuitive right
one would expect that the state would
just have to prove that your guilt is
more likely than not
well so this this this actually reminds
me of what i was talking about two
episodes ago with regard to type 1 and
type 2 errors with regard to
medical and surgical interventions for
children who declare themselves trans
right which kind of error do we do we
prefer do we prefer to make false
positives
and in the case of of of criminal cases
um it's you know do we prefer
to um falsely convict those who are
innocent
or do we prefer to falsely let off those
who are
actually guilty and what are the
founders of this country decided
is that we absolutely 100 prefer um to
let off some people who are guilty
rather than ever
put um rather than ever put an innocent
person behind bars
yes exactly they did it is before those
terms before those statistical terms
ever existed
um they uh made quite clear their logic
and the idea was to prevent the tyranny
of the state which they were of course
keenly aware of in light of what they
had experienced
with great britain the twist here is
that we now
have the danger of the tyranny of the
state under the control of the mob
right and that is a truly frightening
prospect that in effect what we to the
extent that this
was um not the correct verdict
that there was reasonable doubt on the
basis that for example
um and just to be clear i know you've
said it but when you say
that this verdict may not have been
correct you are not actually saying
anything about whether or not
chauvin was is actually guilty you are
saying that the evidence
provided in the case does not appear to
meet the standard
right and it is almost you may also be
making that other point but that is not
that is not certainly not trying to make
that point what i'm trying the point i'm
trying to make is that for example we
had evidence in the case
of george floyd having ingested
substantial
uh quantities of drugs that
would have put him in jeopardy in light
of his heart condition they might have
put him in jeopardy
absent a heart condition but he clearly
had a heart condition he had had covid
and was
therefore compromised and he was under
he was
being arrested and he was uh clearly
panicking which elevated his heart rate
and so the question of whether or not he
died as a result of what chauvin
did or whether or not he died as a
result of the situation
triggering a heart condition to cause
his heart to fail
is one in which it is hard to imagine
how a jury of reasonable people would
not have had
at least some reasonable doubt about
that question um
so in light of the fact that so the
question to be asked is
what other forces were in play right
what other forces were in play and in
fact
and one of the forces is blatantly
obvious which is the the
threat of the mob the threat of the mob
or the desire to do
some kind of justice above and beyond
what the jury's job
was who's to say but um the problem is
you cannot sacrifice an individual
you can't say well chauvin is one man
and uh you know riotous mobs could kill
tens or hundreds we can't do that
calculation we cannot allow ourselves to
do that calculation because
it isn't the 10 or 100 people who might
be injured or killed
in rioting that it's up against it's up
against the protection of the 350
million of us who
are who are insulated from governmental
tyranny
by this principle and so you know in
essence as
counterintuitive as it is that principle
must stand
irrespective of the cost of doing
the right and legal thing in court
um so you know it was clear this was
coming this is why i said it on joe
rogan and i must say it was one of the
most uncomfortable things i have ever
said in my life
in the um you know in the unfolding
emergence of the facts of this case to
say actually you know as everybody was
saying this is clearly murder
and i was saying it's not so clearly
murder this was complex what you need is
a court and i'm
concerned that a court will not be able
to do its job in this case
because of the larger threat of what
will happen if it does
and also what you need as a court
is not a statement that is partisan
it's not a political statement it is a
statement for democracy regardless of
where you stand
left right democrat republican what you
need is a court
in order to make such decisions is
actually what stands between us and
anarchy
anarchy and tyranny and in this case we
may have both
conspiring together and you know yes it
is it is the
it is absolutely unpartisan in fact
the thing that keeps ringing in my ear
is the rosian veil of ignorance
right the reason that you protect this
standard even when
it will free some guilty people right
the reason that you protect this
standard
is because of the justifiable fear that
we should all have
of a government that isn't held to this
standard right
and you know you don't know when it's
going to be on your side versus on
uh your enemy side and so the point is
it's always the error of these partisan
moves isn't it
it's always the error and you know
as we watch the um the educational
apparatus that is supposed to be
upgrading all of our software come apart
and engage in these petty games
i am in my mind constantly building a
list of
things that a proper curriculum should
expose every single person to
as we've been doing for decades right
exactly you know you just
built a list of what should be and one
of the things is rawlsy and veil of
ignorance you know
you need 45 minutes don't you spell it
out the rossian veil of ignorance just
essentially says you shouldn't make
rules that you wouldn't want to live on
the wrong side of right you don't want
to make a rule
that you shouldn't be happy to face and
so
that puts a limit on the kinds of rules
you create and it frankly sidelines most
of this partisan garbage because
you may get an advantage from doing it
on wednesday and then on friday you
suffer the cost of it and
right we don't want to live in that
world right we don't want
you know to for example uh start
increasing the number of people on the
court to compensate for what the last
administration
did because the point is then the next
administration will do it to you and
what you'll have is a you know
we're all supreme court justices now
right we're also
right exactly that's the natural
endpoint of that game
it is it is because in effect it's just
it's a it's a race to the bottom
that all the smart people know you don't
want to trigger right
um so in any case i'm not sure
where to go uh beyond that except to say
that i think everyone who did watch this
trial
if you paid any attention at all you saw
reasonable doubt
right it doesn't mean that you think
that he wasn't
in the end uh responsible for george
floyd's death though
a reasonable person could imagine easily
that he wasn't that george floyd had a
heart attack as a result
of an elevated heart rate and drugs that
he had uh
taken and that he died under chauvin's
knee
for endogenous reasons rather rather
than exogenous ones
but that isn't the point the jury is
instructed
very specifically that the the state
must prove its case beyond a reasonable
doubt and they are
um supposed to exclude the consequences
of saying
one way or the other whether or not the
state met that burden
[Music]
you